der unsichtbare gegner china stoppt alle
gruppen reisen im in- und ins ausland
der präsident warnt vor einer ernsten
lage wegen des corona virus und auch
europa meldet erste fälle suche bei
minusgraden im türkischen erdbebengebiet
hoffen die retter auf überlebende in den
trümmern
große chance oder umweltproblem die
geplante tesla fabrik bei berlin spaltet
die anwohner
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers in einen guten abend
schön dass sie bei uns sind heute um 7
norbert lehmann trägt den sport bei zu
dieser handball und fußball bundesliga
stand und wir beginnen mit einem virus
dass die welt zunehmend in atem hält
chinas präsident spricht jetzt von einer
epidemie die usa frankreich russland
evakuieren ihre bürger aus der stadt wo
hahn in china wo das corona virus zuerst
auftrat und wo es bisher am meisten
infizierten gibt china hat die region
dort komplett abgeriegelt und stopp
jetzt auch alle gruppen reisen im land
und ins ausland das hat es noch nie
gegeben
offiziell gibt es in china mittlerweile
41 tote und fast 1400 infizierte dazu
melden auch immer mehr asiatische
nachbarstaaten einzelfälle genauso wie
australien die usa und jetzt auch europa
3 mit dem neuen corona virus infizierte
gibt es in frankreich axel konrad fasst
die lage zusammen
dass carola virus ist in europa zwei der
infizierten patienten liegen in dieser
pariser klinik unter quarantäne einer in
bordeaux alle patienten waren zuvor in
china
wir überprüfen jetzt mit wem die positiv
getesteten patienten kontakt hat kaum
machten die fälle in frankreich die
runde begann der run auf die apotheken
atemmasken ausverkauft im nu eine maske
habe ich schon ich möchte mich
informieren was ich sonst noch tun kann
die charité in berlin ist führend in der
virologie hier wurden die testverfahren
für das corona virus entwickelt von
professor thorsten er lernt das virus
immer besser kennen und warnt vor panik
insgesamt kann ich nicht sagen es gäbe
einen anhalt für eine aktuelle neue
besorgnis lage nur weil sich die zahlen
erhöht haben das ist etwas ganz normales
und wir werden zwangsläufig auch eine
weitere erhöhung dieser zahlen sehen
denn die meldezahlen schleppen nach das
kann gar nicht anders sein
in johann in china können krankenhäuser
und ärzte dem mann störung der patienten
kaum noch standhalten
die medizinischen hilfsmittel gehen aus
das personal am anschlag
ein arzt ist schon an der viruskrankheit
gestorben
die zentralregierung schickte
verstärkung aus dem ganzen land reisen
trupps von militärärzten an als arzt
muss du dahin wo du gebraucht wirst aber
es wäre gelogen wenn ich sagen würde ich
hätte keine angst und peking verschärft
weiter die maßnahmen gegen die
ausbreitung der seuche aber kommen der
woche sind den chinesen alle gruppen
reisen ins in und ausland untersagt und
wir gehen live nach peking zu unserer
korrespondentin stefanie schöneborn
stefanie das sind ja alarmierende worte
des chinesischen präsidenten heute er
spricht von einer ernsten situation
wie kommt das bei den chinesen an die
chinesen oder die menschen hier in china
sind verunsichert die haben schlicht
angst die zahlen der infizierten steigen
immer weiter gleichzeitig gibt es die
durchhalteparolen der regierung und dann
gibt es diese videos im netz kursieren
immer vermehrter und die krankenhäuser
zeichen zeigen am rande ihrer
belastungsgrenze das misstrauen in die
regierung ist einfach sehr groß und je
stärker die maßnahmen der regierung sind
umso mehr drängt sich bei vielen
menschen hier das gefühl auf dass sie
vor allen dingen am anfang die situation
eigentlich nicht den griff hatten dass
sie sie unterschätzt haben und
vielleicht auch einfach schlicht
überfordert waren
jetzt gibt es ja auch heute wieder neue
sehr drastische maßnahmen ein
komplettverbot von gruppenreisen im in-
und ins ausland was heißt das konkret
na ja wir waren heute in peking
unterwegs und das was wir gesehen haben
an diesem ersten neujahrstag war einfach
eine stadt die komplett leer war das
liegt sicherlich daran dass die
regierung maßnahmen ergriffen hatte
indem sie die tempel zum beispiel hat
schließen lassen
aber viele chinesen haben sich auch
selbst unter quarantäne gestellt weil
sie schlicht ergreifend angst haben
also dieses peking das man sonst kennt
dieses volle pulsierende und auch sehr
laute peking das habe ich tatsächlich
noch nie so vor unsicher
hat und so leer gesehen steffi vielen
dank also massive auswirkungen auf den
tourismus das gefährliche corona virus
ist auf dem vormarsch
ein kurzer überblick über seine
entwicklung wo ist es zum ersten mal
aufgetaucht und wie hat es sich
verbreitet haben wir für sie online
auf heute de oder in der heute app
gestern abend im osten der türkei
die erde bebt häuser stürzen ein bei
manchen bleibt kein stein auf dem
anderen fast 30 menschen sterben mehr
als tausend werden verletzt
unter hochdruck suchen die retter noch
nach rund 20 vermissten
das zentrum des erdbebens lag in der
region ela sie jörg brase berichtet
diese wenn du die stimme des mannes
höher ist sagt ihm er soll weiter
sprechen damit er bei bewusstsein bleibt
rede auch mit seinen kindern die
helferin des katastrophenschutzes
versucht die verschüttete zu beruhigen
während sich die rettungstrupps durch
die trümmer zu ihr vorgaben 43 menschen
konnten sie bislang aus den zerstörten
häusern retten
das beben war stark 6,8 auf der
richterskala
es gab zahlreiche nachbeben das letzte
erst vor wenigen stunden drohnen
aufnahmen am morgen zeigen dass gestern
abend in der stadt zürich wohl
tatsächlich nur fünf häuser einstürzten
in einem nachbarort waren es 25
der rest hielt dem beben stand denn es
gelten strenge bauvorschriften die aber
werden immer wieder unterlaufen
am nachmittag besucht auch präsident
erdogan die orte der katastrophe die
rettungskräfte arbeiten auf hochtouren
um die menschen aus den trümmern zu
ziehen
sie gehen jeder stimme nach die sie
hören so können sie nach 17 stunden auch
diese lebend aus den trümmern bergen
sie ist stark unterkühlt aber wohlauf
nach den anderen eingeschlossenen wird
immer noch gesucht
nach deutschland und da zu einem thema
das für die spd ein prestige objekt und
für die union zunehmend ein rotes tuch
ist die grundrente ob und wie sie kommt
weiß derzeit niemand die
rentenversicherung sieht
verfassungsrechtliche und praktische
hindernisse und mehrere unions geführte
ministerien halten
grundrente sowie arbeitsminister
hubertus heil sich das vorstellt nicht
für umsetzbar
britta spiekermann jetzt mit mehr saskia
esken parteivorsitzender der spd heute
auf dem landesparteitag in oschersleben
in sachsen anhalt
natürlich spielt auch hier der neuen
pflanze streit mit der union über die
grundrente eine rolle
immer wieder damit anfängt ist ist
wirklich ärgerlich weil die menschen
warten darauf dass wir diese rente
ermöglichen
wie gesagt im respekt vor der
lebensleistung auch ausgezahlt werden
soll
und die muss jetzt kommen die wird sehr
sehr viele menschen besser absichern im
alter was dringend notwendig ist
im fokus der kritik steht
arbeitsminister hubertus heil
sein ursprünglicher plan den
gesetzentwurf am kommenden mittwoch im
kabinett zu beraten und zu beschließen
ist vom tisch
auf der bremse steht die union sie
kritisiert die finanzierung stehe auf
wackligen füßen der geplante renten
zuschlag für langjährig beschäftigte
geringverdiener soll weitestgehend aus
der finanztransaktionssteuer finanziert
werden durch diese steuer gibt es noch
nicht
gesundheitsminister sparen spricht von
weiteren lehrstellen im gesetzentwurf
etwa inwieweit bei der geplanten
einkommensüberprüfung auch weitere
einkünfte zum beispiel aus
kapitalvermögen berücksichtigt werden
damit auch nur diejenigen den renten
zuschlag bekommen die ihn auch wirklich
brauchen spd cdu csu haben im
koalitionsausschuss vereinbart
einkommensanrechnung mit allen
einkünften die jemand hat und diese
vereinbarung muss dann verdammt noch mal
auch vom bundesfinanzminister opfer
bundesarbeitsminister mit einem
gangbaren vorschlag ins gesetz
hineingeschrieben werden
zudem befürchtet die union eine
benachteiligung von ehepaaren bei ihnen
sollen die einkünfte des partners mit
eingerechnet werden
bei unverheirateten paaren dagegen nicht
für cdu/csu ist das verfassungswidrig
er ist ein diktator und wahrheit hat
einen wert sonst sind wir verloren
das waren heftige vorwürfe und beinahe
verzweifelte appelle der demokraten im
us-senat sie sind die ankläger im
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen den
amerikanischen präsidenten
sie hatten jetzt insgesamt 24 stunden
zeit für ihre plädoyers
genauso viel zeit wie die
republikanischen verteidiger von donald
trump die ab heute am zug sind in ist
ramms trotz regens sind sie gekommen ein
paar wenige die vor dem senat für die
amtsenthebung von präsident trump
demonstrieren
drinnen beim verfahren haben heute seine
anwälte das wort ihre leitlinie trump
habe nichts falsch gemacht den
demokraten unterstellen sie rein
politische motive für das
amtsenthebungsverfahren sie wollten tram
von der wahl im herbst fernhalten
sie bitten sie die stimmzettel zu
zerreißen die entscheidung bei dieser
wahl den amerikanischen wählern
wegzunehmen
am abend hatten die anklagevertreter der
demokraten ihr plädoyer beendet trump
hatte sein amt missbraucht als er die
ukraine um wahl hilfe gebeten habe und
die ermittlungen des kongresses
behindert ihn mögen oder nicht das
spielt keine rolle es geht darum dass er
eine gefahr für unser land darstellt er
will über mächtig sein er respektiert
den kongress den vertreter des volkes
nicht nur sein wille zählt
er ist ein diktator das darf so nicht
bleiben trump wollte die us
botschafterin für die ukraine rauswerfen
als sie seine pläne durchkreuzte das
macht nun der mitschnitt eines gesprächs
deutlich
die demokraten wollen belege wie diesen
im prozess verwenden auch zeugen
vernehmen unwahrscheinlich jedoch ob sie
das gegen die republikanische mehrheit
im senat durchsetzen können und wieder
zurück zu uns nach deutschland das ist
eine milliardeninvestition aber sie hat
ihre gegner vor drei monaten hatte der
autokonzern tesla bekannt gegeben dass
er in brandenburg ein riesiges werk
bauen will und 4000 arbeitsplätze
schaffen
hier soll das werk entstehen 1 300
hektar großes gelände bereits ab mitte
nächsten jahres sollen dort elektroautos
vom band rollen von berlin sind es rund
40 kilometer östlich nach grünheide und
dort gibt es heute demonstrationen für
und gegen den baubeginn erwarten
sie machen sich sorgen um ihren ort ihre
heimat auf dem marktplatz von grünheide
protestieren heute die die nicht wollen
dass tesla hier eine neue fabrik baut
sie befürchten zu viel verkehr haben
angst um das trinkwasser und den wald
wir sind nicht gegen tesla sondern wie
geht sind gegen den standort der in
einem wasserschutzgebiet errichtet
werden soll
hundertwasser uns abgegraben wird ich
habe hier in der nähe ein haus und ich
habe eigentlich vor mein leben hier zu
bleiben kann kein kran mit haus
wegnehmen
ich möchte gerne die natur erhalten doch
der kiefernwald muss weichen die rodung
soll schon nächsten monat beginnen
seit jahren ist das gelände als
gewerbegebiet ausgewiesen
deshalb kann jetzt alles schnell gehen
vor 20 jahren hatten wir den großen
traum dass ich bmw hier ansiedelt dass
es damals gescheitert der bebauungsplan
über die 300 hektar ist für bmw erstellt
worden und seitdem rechtskräftigen davon
profitiert tesla
doch die firma nimmt auch bedenken auf
elenas twittert heute hört sich so an
als ob wir ein paar dinge klarstellen
müssen
tesla wird nicht täglich so viel
leitungswasser entnehmen gutachten
müssen jetzt klären welche auflagen
tesla erfüllen muss viele grünheider
sind auch zuversichtlich dass er seine
schöne innovation für unser dorf und das
kann auf jeden fall viele vorteile für
die zukunft mit sich bringen das ist ein
unternehmen was antritt den klimawandel
mit zu stoppen ökologisch gut zu
wirtschaften und von da habe ich da auch
hohes vertrauen
rund 4000 neue jobs sollen entstehen
eine große chance für die ganze region
aber auch eine riesenherausforderung für
grünheide und jetzt ganz viel samstags
sport zusammengefasst von norbert
wir fangen an mit der handball-em da
ging es heute in stockum für deutschland
um platz 5 eigentlich unbedeutend aber
für das dhb team dann doch eine frage
der ehre
deutschland gewann das duell gegen
portugal rückenwind für die
olympia-quali im april
das ist ein versöhnlicher abschluss
dieser europameisterschaft für die
deutsche mannschaft die partie ist lange
ausgeglichen gegen das überraschungsteam
aus portugal das gewohnt variantenreich
spielt in der schlussphase allerdings
deutschland treffsicherer julius kühn
das 26 26 durch den besten deutschen
werfer mit insgesamt sechs toren
den schlusspunkt setzt marian michalczyk
29 zu 27 wir sind fünfter geworden haben
unser ziel knapp verfehlt um einen platz
aber das ist eben leider so im
welthandball dass du 67 teams fast jedes
mal den anspruch haben neben teilen zu
spielen nun geht der blick richtung
olympia-qualifikation im april in berlin
gegner dann unter anderem schweden und
slowenien dritte saison niederlage für
fußball-bundesligist rb leipzig der
tabellenführer verlor in frankfurt gegen
die eintracht hier die bisherigen
ergebnisse des 19
spieltags frankfurt schlägt leipzig 20
gladbach gewinnt gegen mainz mit 3 2 1
wolfsburg unterliegt härter mit 1
2-heimpleite auch für freiburg nur zu 2
gegen paderborn union berlin bezwingt
augsburg mit 2 zu 0 das abendspiel
bayern gegen schalke bereits gestern
dortmund gegen köln 5 zu 1 die beiden
sonntagsspiele bremen gegen hoffenheim
und leverkusen gegen düsseldorf die
tabelle
leipzig trotz der niederlage weiterhin
erster der abstand auf gladbach aber nur
noch zwei punkte dann die bayern auf
rang drei die können sich heute noch auf
den zweiten platz verbessern
dortmund weiterhin vierter und schalke
fünfter leverkusen sechster die zweite
tabellenhälfte beginnt mit wolfsburg und
im tabellenkeller bremen sechzehnter
paderborn hat die rote laterne für heute
erstmal an düsseldorf abgegeben und das
abendspiel bayern gegen schalke
ausführlich dem aktuell
ein sportstudium 23 uhr zu gast bei
jochen breyer marcel halstenberg von
tabellenführer rb leipzig deutschlands
beste tennisspielerin angelique kerber
hat bei den australian open das
achtelfinale erreicht ebenso wie
deutschlands bester tennisspieler
alexander das wäre auch sein dritter
sieg in melbourne ohne satzverlust
gut aber nicht perfekt fand zverev sein
match gegen den 14 jahre älteren spanier
fernando verdasco hier oben im bild die
formkrise vom saisonauftakt war zverev
nicht mehr anzumerken nur im dritten
satz verlor er ein aufschlagspiel der
rest war souverän nach 6 2 6 2 und 6 zu
4 stets werde in der runde der besten 16
angelique kerber hatte gegen camila
giorgi mehr mühe die italienerin hier
unten machte viel mehr fehler
doch kerber kam nicht ins spiel ich kann
nicht mehr es geht nicht mehr war im
letzten satz von ihr zu hören
doch trotz leichter
oberschenkelverletzung kämpfte sich die
dreimalige grand-slam-gewinnerin nach
mehr als zwei stunden zum sieg mit 6 zu
2 6 7 und 6 zu 3 im achtelfinale spielt
sie am montag gegen die russin anastasia
pawljutschenkowa
die deutschen skispringer haben den
mannschaftswettbewerb im polnischen
zakopane gewonnen
konstantin schmidt markus eisenbichler
der falle und karl geiger verwiesen
norwegen und slowenien souverän auf die
plätze zwei und drei
den weitesten deutschen sprung landete
der gesamtweltcupführende karl geiger
mit 1 142 meter
das war es von mir da kann die noch
norbert vielen dank das wetter
beisteuern trüb und anfangs glatt für
die einen strahlend sonnig für die
anderen die wetter gegensätze sind bei
uns im moment sehr groß details gleich
von katja oliver ich empfehle ihnen sehr
das heute journal mit der kollegin
marietta slomka um 22 45 und ich kann
ihnen zusagen dass wir auch morgen
wieder für sie da sind bis dann in allen
einen angenehmen samstagabend tschüss
[Musik]
meine damen und herren dass es im januar
schneit ist ja an sich keine nachricht
in diesem januar aber schon denn bislang
war es ja viel zu mild jetzt ändert sich
das wetter und das liegt an einem
sturmtief das braus war vor allen dingen
über die britischen inseln streift uns
aber im nordwesten und dann wird es
markant kühler heute nacht sinken die
temperaturen auf 2 grad in
schleswig-holstein bis -4 grad im
thüringer wald überall gibt es also
bodenfrost und sie müssen sich auf
gefährlich glatte straßen einstellen
entweder durch reifglätte wenn sich
wieder dichter nebel mit zum teil
geringen sichtweiten bildet oder wenn
gefrierender nieselregen aus dieser
hochnebeldecke herausfällt
auch morgen bleibt es zum teil wieder
sehr trüb zum beispiel hier in
mainfranken oder auch an der donau im
nordwesten haben sie größere chancen
noch mal die sonne zu sehen
ähnlich wie im südwesten denn der wind
nimmt schon ein bisschen zu ihr kommt
aus südwestlichen richtungen
wenn es morgen den ganzen tag über trüb
bleibt dann liegen die temperaturen nur
so bei ein bis zwei grad sonst werden um
die 5 grad erreicht an der ems am rhein
und auch im alpenvorland geht's auf acht
bis elf grad rauf am montag kommt dann
von westen regen heran
danach wird es deutlich kälter dann
fällt schnee nicht nur in den höchsten
lagen der mittelgebirge erst gibt's
sturm an der nordsee und dann an der
ostsee
schönes wochenende